party
we-we-we stop the movie why is the
skateboarding guitar playing cute girl
dating 17 year old friends with an AARP
card carrying plutonium stealing flux
capacitor creating crackpot science does
no one else find it slightly odd that
they're meeting in an empty mall parking
lot at 1:15 in the morning I mean this
isn't your normal high school friendship
they don't copy each other's biology
homework they don't complain about girls
they don't go movies on Friday nights
no Marty McFly and dr. Emmett Brown have
more of a bros don't let bros steal
plutonium from living in nationalist
kind of thing going on doc you don't
just walk into a store and buy plutonium
Joe Mullaney hilariously pointed this
out in his Netflix special the comeback
kid who's his best friend the disgraced
nuclear physicist all right bro seed and
he's right it's a little [ __ ] weird
not quite your mom having the hots for
you weird but just weird Bob Gale the
film's co-writer and co-creator of the
entire Back to the Future universe gave
us his reason for doc and Marty's
friendship back in 2011 for yours marty
was told that Doc Brown was dangerous a
crackpot a lunatic so being a
red-blooded American teenage boy age 13
or 14 he decided to find out just why
this guy was so dangerous
marty snuck into Doc's lab and was
fascinated by all the cool stuff that
was there when Doc found him there he
was delighted to find that marty thought
he was cool and accepted him for what he
was 13 or 14 years old Bobby made it
weird or first off pick a year was a 13
or was a 14 this is your universe
there's no reason to be vague and what
cool stuff was Marty fascinated by a
rueful clocks
an automated can opener an overpowered
speaker that almost killed him
at face value Marty seems like a pretty
cool kid as I mentioned before he's in a
band he can skateboard he plays guitar
and he has an attractive girlfriend well
what other friends does Marty have
in fact what friends does Marting make
over the course of three movies we see
him with his band but there doesn't seem
to be any camaraderie amongst him in any
of the other pinheads in the future he
still seems like a loner who's kind of
stepped on by all the superiors and in
the Wild West his only friends are his
ancestors who suspiciously look a lot
like him don't get me started on his
incredibly depressing family life
his dad's a pushover and his mom's an
overbearing alcoholic what does Marty
truly love music the franchise starts
with Marty getting blown away 30 feet by
a speaker he brainwashes his father with
heavy metal music and he lives his dream
of performing up a high school dance by
playing Johnny he did it when we first
encountered dark-brown in the past and
November 5th 1955 you might not notice a
saxophone hanging the background of his
workshop so let's say bud pillows right
they meant innocently early in the 1980s
to owners who want so much more from
life behind over their mutual love for
music once stuck with the shitty home
life trying to grasp this future the
other a disgraced scientist struggling
with the constant failures of his past
it's innocent enough but still something
just doesn't quite add up which brings
me to my next theory what else do
slacker teenagers love sleep Marty is
constantly sleeping or passed out or
knocked unconscious over the course of
the trilogy and every time he wakes up
he's very confused and disoriented but
like most slacker as Marty as a kid with
big dreams getting signed by the record
company taking Jennifer up to the lake
and maybe possibly
of time-traveling with imaginary best
friend who can fix all the problems in
his life
maybe Marty McFly is a lucid dreamer
it's all a dream just a very intense
treat and he dreams up the time
traveling to Orion and he dreams up the
good kind and loyal friend and it makes
sense because he's in desperate need of
one someone or something to make the
pain go away his Oedipus complex with
his mom subconscious his triumphant
strut across the hill Valley High School
Auditorium stage pure aspirational
imagination if you put your mind to it
you can accomplish anything how else do
you explain mr. Strickland never agent
lets either that or Marty met doc
innocently as writer Bob Gale said
around the age of 13 or 14 and he's been
hanging around Doc's workshop for three
to four years and somehow never noticed
or heard doc talk about his thirty year
mission of building a time machine are
you kidding me and all this time around
his best bud Martin II never heard one
mention of the infamous flux capacitor
never once saw DeLorean are we really
supposed to believe that the inquisitive
morning and finding never asked doc what
he was working on or that Doc Brown
wouldn't tell his only friend that he
invented time travel I call [ __ ]
Marty McFly is asleep dreaming obscure
Lewis and the news tunes time-traveling
in the dope Dewar Ian with his kooky
best friend Doc Brown fixing the past
and attempt to make his actual real life
lonely presents lightly more powerful
too dark okay well let me go back and
touch on that whole thing with Marty and
his mom for one second
[Music]